même si on est président chancelière on
est humain et après plus de seize heures
de négociations on est loin d'avoir le
teint frais et les idées claires tous
s'entendaient pour dire qu'il y aurait
bel et bien cessez-le-feu en ukraine
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche et que
deux jours plus tard on éloignerait les
armes lourdes de la ligne de front entre
troupe ukrainienne et rebelle pro-russe
pour créer une zone tampon et éviter une
reprise des hostilités
mais sur bien des détails on avait des
perceptions différentes
des quatre leaders le président françois
hollande semblait le plus optimiste
sommes arrivés à un accord
un accord sur le cessez-le-feu et sur un
règlement politique globale la
chancelière allemande angela merkel
étaient plus nuancées
elle concluait qu'il y avait une lueur
d'espoir après cet accord la même
expression qu'elle avait utilisé juste
avant ce marathon de négociations il ya
encore bien des obstacles devant nous
disent elles mais plusieurs désaccords
subsistent entre les présidents
ukrainien et russe
vladimir poutine admettait que la nuit
qu'il venait de passer n'était pas la
plus agréable de sa vie il affirmait que
toute solution durable passait d'abord
par une réforme constitutionnelle qu'ils
respecteraient les droits des rebelles
pro russe le président ukrainien petro
prochain coup ni est fortement s'est
engagée de la sorte a accordé une
autonomie ou une forme d'indépendance
aux pro russe
malgré les pressions nous n'avons pas
accepté une autonomie pour ces gens mais
bien de la décentralisation disait-il
la journée était loin d'être terminée
les leaders français allemands et
ukrainiens se sont rendus ensuite au
sommet de l'union européenne à bruxelles
où la nouvelle de l'accord de minsk a
été accueillie avec réserve
six femmes le premier ministre
britannique david cameron reflétait la
pensée de plusieurs andy laroche qu'il
s'agissait de vrai cessez le feu c'était
bien mais monsieur poutine devra changer
d'attitude s'emploie les sanctions
contre la russie vont rester alors
pourquoi autant de scepticisme après un
accord est bien d'abord selon le je
craignais pendant que le président
poutine négocier en pleine nuit la
russie est livré des armes lourdes aux
rebelles en ukraine et puis il ya déjà
eu l accord semblable à minsk aussi en
septembre dernier un accord qui s'est
vite envolée en fumée alors maintenant
c'est méfiance méfiance et si raymond
st-pierre radio canada à moscou